make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay fYI for those of you guys you know
for those you guys you haven't seen in
game yet this is gonna have in game
spoilers I don't know anybody who has a
seen in game yet but again like tickets
were pretty hard to come by when they
first went on sale it's sold like that
like it's it's sold out normal sibling
given I know let me recover more comics
today but this is more important and so
so the question the question people have
is what comes next in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right like what now
now that all this stuff is going down
also this happen and essentially like
the Avengers have totally been shifted
up well here's the thing like what I
want to see and I think what most
everybody wants to see is like the x-men
of the fantastic and and here's reason
why well this is technically called the
Infinity Saga this last ten years you
can really just kind of get away with
calling it like the Avengers era right
because it was all about the Avengers it
was the formation of the Avengers it was
how the Avengers functioned once they're
made is like the first big threat they
face after they face Loki when the team
officially forms he also you go on the
Ultron then you go on the Santos and the
the on running theme the whole
undercurrent to all this these last ten
years whatever was is that you basically
had like Thanos trying to gather the
Infinity stones and it all comes to a
head and Evan yours in-game so the
question becomes what comes next
okay so my thought is looking at face
for right because it's way too early to
talk about phase five though my thought
is looking at face for rolling in the
x-men and rollin in the Fantastic Four
ideally I would like to see Secret Wars
and as far as I'm aware of the Russo
brothers are twenty around with the idea
but I would want to see Secret Wars
right and actually you know one of the
films on this list here that I have
actually kind of sets up for it really
offers like a really really early set up
for so in the MC I'm sorry in the
interview with faith for the films that
we're listing off here as far as I'm
aware have not started filming yet and
haven't even really started
pre-production
they're just ideas that exist out there
and they want to release them somewhere
online a few of them have like Black
Widow is sort of pre-production so on
and so forth and the filming of it
actually starts in June of this year so
I guess the 2019 anyway so yeah so so so
so here's the thing for me when it comes
to introducing the x-men in the
Fantastic Four it's all about the slow
build remember
how you felt when you saw like Captain
America shield and Ironman or like the
post-credits scene with Thor's hammer or
when like like Tony Stark walks in and
talks to Thunderbolt Ross about the
Avengers or even the post-credits scene
in the first Ironman when Nick Fury says
I want to talk to you about the Avengers
initiative like but how how cool was
that like you remember how you felt
because from that point going forward
from I oh man going forward it was
Easter eggs it was a scavenger hunt
right there was like what do we see in
this movie both obvious clues and non
obvious clues that indicate like what's
coming later on down line what
characters we're going to see and like
how they show up and so looking at this
my first thought goes to Black Widow no
the Black Widow film as far as I'm aware
and from what they what they said is
that it should be a sequel that takes
place in the 2000s before she shows up
in Iron Man 2 which is cool because you
know again with Avengers in game Black
Widow is dead and gone now they've said
that once a person sacrifices their life
in order to gain the soul from the soul
stone from from you know wherever it
comes from soul world then basically
like there's no way to make them return
I don't think that's true I think it's
just like there's no way to make them
return because we haven't thought of one
yet but as soon as like they need to
bring Black Widow back which otherwise
you would but as soon as it like we need
to bring Black Widow back
well then suddenly they figured out a
way you know Doctor Strange is like oh I
found a spell then let's be going to the
afterlife and borrow you know barter
with mistress death and release the soul
of Black Widow and she's back now you
know and um that probably won't happen
since the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
kind of a combination of earth 98 and
and the ultimate universe those guys
don't know earth 98 was an alternate
universe in Marvel Comics where heroes
aged in real time and then of course the
ultimate universe was what if Heroes
existed right now so it's kind of a
merged kind of a blend between the two
but assuming Black Widow is a prequel
what you do is you basically have some
scenario where like she's working with
shield or whatever government she's with
you know she's with like the Russians or
whatever where they send her on a
mission and she has to work alongside
team X and that's it that's this
literally that's the x-men but you know
the the xmin being rolled in here's
reason why Team X was a black ops wet
work team and Marvel Comics that
Wolverine Sabretooth
other people were part of before they
were brought into weapons plus right
like they worked for the CIA and when I
see a black ops team they did it at all
right they topple governments they kill
political officials they did it all like
like if if a hit was taken out on you
like if the government was like we're
sitting Team X after you you were gonna
die and that's just the way it was and
they would come down perform their
missions in a couple of different ways
either they would do like the hand where
they basically snuck in and they're
really clandestine and really really
quiet and nobody knew they were there
they were in and out before anybody had
any idea would happen and like they
would kill you without waking up the cat
or they would go in just guns blazing
right they were just like shoot
everything up and that would be the end
that they were like the trimmer'
brothers from from smokin aces they
would go in just shoot everything up and
kill like 21 people just to get to one
guy like it was it was nuts but because
of the fact it was it was really kind of
like the CIA basically saying what would
happen if we took individuals who had
powers and then turn him into a blackops
team and then send them out to perform
missions now after that eventually
weapons Plus learned about them and they
were thrown into the weapons Plus
program and they became weapon tents so
um our webinars a lot of you guys would
call it but like you literally have her
fight alongside them and in like like
you don't really you don't really see it
happen like you don't see like Wolverine
Sabretooth you don't see all those guys
it's just she reports back from like
some mission right where like you have
yeah that scene from Captain America
where they were like kept America the
Winter Soldier I think what they were
like they had just gotten back from some
mission and then they were going on
another one that's literally what you do
and it's just like how do things go with
Team X and it's like oh man things were
crazy do that guy James Howlett like
James Howlett and Victor Creed those
guys are crazy I'm really kind of
worried they're gonna lose their minds
one day James Holliday will reign Victor
Creed being saber-toothed Easter egg
done and like they're in the MCU from
there you go to the Eternals and the
Eternals film that's the movie that
explains why mutant genes exist in the
first place and that's less it literally
like you don't have you'll do it on the
nose you just say like at some early
point in human history the celestial
showed up on earth and they modify the
genes of early man and like one third of
the group that was experimenting on the
Wanderers is what it would call but what
group of The Wanderers were
experimenting on they became the
deviants which are basically trolls and
monsters the second group became angelic
beings who were the Eternals and the
third their genes would manifest
somewhere along the line and he
literally say like they you Teta their
genes and they'll manifest somewhere
along one bam x-men like literally just
like okay so this is where mutants come
from this is the origin of the mutant
population and that's it it's not a it's
not like a plot it's not like a third of
the movie right like the first third of
the movie is not the Eternals being like
we're modifying genes and mutants will
arrive and like fifty thousand years you
don't say that it's just it's it's one
of those things where like the audience
will understand and those that don't
we'll have it explained to them by me so
from there you go into Doctor Strange -
and Doctor Strange - sets up secret Wars
and the way this plays out is you
basically have Doctor Strange doing
whatever he's doing some campaign
submission or whatever is this going on
and it's passing through dimensions and
one of the dimensions he passes through
is to be on verse other be on dimension
or whatever it is and like like
literally okay so here's the thing about
the honors the beyonders are beings you
have two versions of them right you have
the the Beyonder from the original
secret wars and 1984 and then you have
to be honors from jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers the beyonders
from hitman offenders and New Avengers
did not look anything like the original
Beyond and the question was why do they
have the same name if they're totally
different and hikmah to answer that and
said the way it worked out was that the
original Beyonder from Secret Wars in
1984 he was a child unit he was
basically a kid and liked to beyonders
that you saw and hickman offenders of
New Avengers they were grown adults and
they were pissed they were due they
killed everybody it was man
god I okay here's the thing I understand
like some people just kind like oh my
god here we go again yes here we go
again I know I always go off on tangents
whenever it comes to Hickman's offenders
and new lenders do the beyonders killed
everything
they killed every like everyone and
everything the only things that did not
die were mistress death and the one
above all and that was in like
everything else was dead oblivion was
dead Galactus was dead all the
Celestials were dead all the cosmic
entities infinity eternity the whole
nine yards they were all dead in every
universe that existed right like it
wasn't just the main Marvel Universe it
was this battle happening across the
entire multiverse
so like imagine Oh a battle have
imagined
same conflict happening across every
single universe at the same time that's
Lily when it was the Living Tribunal
shows up the walking talking living
embodiment of the multiverse virtually
I'm like nah I'm nipa ttan almost
completely indestructible was wiped out
by the yzb otters they killed everyone
right like it was it was crazy
anyway the way this plays out is you say
okay so Doctor Strange is passing
through dimensions or whatever and like
piques the interest of the original
beyond basically like a child and this
child's like I wonder who that guy is
and where he's going because it doesn't
know anything outside of its own its own
realm right so I was like I wonder who
that guy isn't where he's going and it
follows him and then follows him back to
the main Marvel Universe and then just
watches and basically like you have all
these events that are transpiring that
piqued the interest of the blue yonder
and that goes into like that the movie
that comes out ten years from now super
wars whether it be on doors like all the
villains and all the heroes you all get
to find each other and like that's
that's literally where that comes from
so that sets that up right now that's
that's the long game so that's not an
immediate set up that's the long game
set up now here's one of the really
really cool things all right then the
next - next next two ones I think are
the coolest ones black panther 2 sets up
the Fantastic Four and here's a reason
why my initial thought was like okay so
basically like humanity's gonna want to
chart the Stars one day right because I
didn't like the idea that I had was
before the events of Avengers in game
right so I was looking at infinity war
and I was saying okay somewhere along
the line felt like thousand dates earth
humanity realizes there's threats
outside of the world beyond like what
they saw in the first Avengers and like
while a threat was stopped what there
are those who are going to come to earth
and try to like I'm Miley humanity or
something like that so so basically like
humans need to achieve interstellar
travel and so they go to what Conda
because at the end of my Panther you
have to Charlton said we want to open
our borders up to the world and we want
to become more involved with the world
we don't want to be like isolated and
totally shut off and so as a result
Black Panther made like literally what
humanity would do is it would go to
Black Panther and they were saying hey
look what we want to kind of in like
merger technology with ours and then
achieve interstellar travel that was my
original idea but at the end of Avengers
in game Santos's ship is on earth and so
because of the fact that is on earth
it's taken by the federal government but
Tony Stark is dead and so the federate
is kind of like well we don't know we
don't know how to make heads or tails of
this thing like we don't know
all this stuff works and so what they
end up doing is they basically say okay
we've got this this dislike genius Reed
Richards or whatever it is so literally
you have Reed Richards it kind of works
on a little bit but even Reed Richards
is kind of struggling a bit so what they
do is they grab Sheree and they bring
Sheree in from Wakanda and this is not
the plot of the movie right like it's
some side things sure he's like well
I've got to go to America to help the
healthy Americans with like technology
because you know how stupid they are
something like that I don't know but
like regardless sure he ends up working
with with like Reed Richards in the
government or the reverse engineer all
of the analysis technology and then in
turn like Reed Richards like company are
gonna be the ones who are gonna who
we're gonna launch the ship into space
as part of sword and they're gonna be
the ones who basically explore the
universe like the sword being the
sentient world observation and response
department those are guys who were new
think of shield except they monitor
space instead of just earth and so what
would happen is like in this first
encounter like it would just it would
just be a be a scene and then we'd go
into a post-credits or something like
that but sure he would like meet Reed
Richards and he would be like hey Sheree
thanks for helping us I'm Reed Richards
she's like I'm Sheree awesome to meet
you done like that's it Fantastic Four
the Marvel Cinematic Universe it's as
simple as that then you go into
shang-chi and change he I think would be
cool right now here's a funny thing back
when when Iron Fist first launched
people were just like they should make
Iron Fist Asian yeah that makes sense
because only Asian people know martial
arts like obviously not true and then my
other thought was well that's kind of a
stupid thing to do because like there's
already an Asian master martial artist
his name is Shane Chi so so it's cool
that we're getting that we're getting
shaky in the MCU but I wouldn't make
like the x-men like I wouldn't do it
like super on the notes right maybe one
of the coolest Easter eggs so what you
do is you have change he actually
crossover for a second with spider-man
and Shane chichi teaches spider-man the
way of the spider those you guys who
don't know the way of the spider is
actually Peter Parker's martial arts
style that was taught to him by Shane
Chi and what you end up doing here is
you basically say that like when Peter
Parker gets in there because you guys
know how you guys don't have Tom
polonaise Peter Parker
he's just so curious about everything so
he gets in there and he's like looking
around and touching things and looking
at things that so on and so forth and
like picks up this sword and Shange he's
like do not touch that sword
that's the Muramasa blade and so he's
like he's like this it's super important
stuff like that put it back and so Peter
Parker puts it back but them the
Muramasa blade in the MCU is huge
because a Marvel Comics
it's the only weapon that can kill wolf
rain but keep him dead permanently and
then in like the in the comics he was in
casein adamantium and that's one of the
ways had killed him but in terms of
weapons nothing look nothing will kill
him except the Muramasa blade
carbonadium slows his healing factor but
as long as he takes time to recover
then his human factor will go back to
the way it was the Muramasa blade will
shut down his healing factor in its
entirety you stab him with the Muramasa
blade and his healing factor is gone
same thing with Deadpool like it's the
only way to really kill them and so so
literally like the only weapon that can
kill Wolverine exists in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and it's in the
possession of shang-chi the master
martial artists right like the guy that
everybody goes to whenever like it's
like hey we need something I've been
fight really well or like we need
training in martial arts there's this I
love the idea of slow builds right now
remember if I have another one in here
and I think that's where it stops with
change he yeah and then a Guardians 3
introduces Adam warlock but um that's my
pitch like that's that's my idea how do
you how to slow build the x-men into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and then from
there if you want to start rolling in
things like Xavier and you want to start
rolling in like the Xavier school for
gifted youngsters that's the thing on
the news right like there's some movie
somewhere or something whatever whatever
movie it happens to be and like
somebody's watching TV for a second and
it's like any Xavier school of gifted
youngsters and then you know they go do
whatever it is they end up doing but
it's like a small little mention or
something like that or like you know
there was actually somebody you
mentioned in my comments or on Twitter
or something like that they were talking
about Doctor Doom and they were saying
like like you know people are like like
social media still upset with Doctor
Doom for refusing to allow people to
interline furia following like the
events of Avengers in game or something
like that or like Liberia is still cut
off from the rest of the world and no
one knows how like the whole snap
impacted them or whatever the case is
but like something to show the Liberia
super secretive and like dr. doom does
not let anyone in or anyone out but but
still like there's a lot of ways to roll
these characters into the MCU because
the slow build is what people like
that's what people love people love
Easter eggs they love going on a hunt
they left trying to figure out this clue
and that clue and that clue and see how
it ties into the bigger picture and how
good we'll all come together let me know
what you guys think I'm really kind of
curious to see where you're all stances
but with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as
explain and make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Roth
poor if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
[Music]
you